qu'est ce qui vous ferait plaisir au
menu dans ce restaurant de versailles du
fromage la star des plats d'hiver s'est
faufilé dans chaque plat présent à la
carte de l'entrée jusqu'au dessert
le principe de ce restaurant c'est de
mêler à la fois des fromages coller de
france avec des plats également gaulle
ils vont faire un petit mélange est de
rester sur le thème principal les
fromages y un filet mignon sault saint
félicien un pavé de saumon rôti ou saint
maur à chaque viande sa sauce fromagère
et pour les plus grands amateurs le
plateau permet une dégustation des
arrivages du jour c'était parfait et des
frais de très bon et en plus cela la
déclinaison des fromages de plus en plus
fort c'est une très bonne idée des
fromages forts mais aussi plus léger
avec au moins 1200 variétés de fromages
produits en france
le consommateur a du choix les réticents
au caractère et à l'auteur du maroilles
peuvent trouver saveurs à leur palais
c'est vrai que moi même je suis pas très
fromage
j'ai un peu du mal avec ce qu'ils sont
assez fort mais honnêtement non je
trouve ça très sympa eu le petit plat
que mon mon beau père a pris avec la
déclinaison fromage effectivement ça
vaut le coup les français sont les plus
gros consommateurs de fromages au monde
avec en moyenne 25 kg par habitant
chaque année ils sont fiers de leur
terroir qui s'exporte 35% de la
production française est consommé à
l'étranger c'est quand même un de nos
fins ninon plus important produit pour
la gastronomie fromages français est
quand même réputés sur le podium des
fromages préféré des français
les mentale vendu à 146 mille tonnes par
an suivi du camembert et du coup l'onu
[Musique]